.
YOU'RE RIGHT, UNEMPLOYMENT NOT
SO GREAT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>>> FLORIDA'S GOVERNOR IS
DECLARING A STATE OF EMERGENCY
TODAY BECAUSE OF A TOXIC
WASTEWATER POND NEAR TAMPA BAY
IS IN DANGER OF BREACHING.
THE PINEY POINT RESERVOIR AT AN
OLD PHOSPHATE PLANT IS
SURROUNDED BY RADIOACTIVE
MATERIAL, THOUGH OFFICIALS SAY
THAT THE WATER IS NOT
RADIOACTIVE.
FLORIDA OFFICIALS HAVE EVACUATED
A NEARBY JAIL AND MORE THAN 300
HOMES.
JANET SHAMLIAN IS IN PALMETTO,
FLORIDA, TRACKING EFFORTS TO
KEEP THE RESERVOIR SAFE.
>> Reporter: MILLIONS OF GALLONS
OF WASTEWATER FOR DAYS HAVE BEEN
RELEASED INTO FLORIDA WATERWAYS,
INCLUDING TAMPA BAY, TO RELIEVE
STRESS ON THE RETAINING WALLS.
IN A DESPERATE EFFORT TO AVOID
AN ENVIRONMENTAL DISASTER.
>> WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT NOW IS
TRYING TO PREVENT AND RESPOND TO
IF NEED BE A REAL CATASTROPHIC
FLOOD SITUATION.
>> Reporter: OFFICIALS SAY THE
POND AT AN OLD FERTILIZER PLANT
HOLDS 4 0 MILLION GALLONS OF
POLLUTED WATER.
A MIX OF SALTWATERS, STORM
RUNOFF, AND ACIDIC WATER
CONTAINING PHOSPHOROUS AND
NITROGEN.
RON DeSANTIS DENIED REPORTS IT'S
RADIOACTIVE.
>> THE WATER MEETS WATER QUALITY
STANDARD FOR MARINE WATERS WITH
THE EXCEPTION PRIMARILY OF THE
PHOSPHOROUS AND THE NITROGEN.
>> Reporter: THE PINEY POINT
PHOSPHATE PLANT CLOSED 20 YEARS
AGO.
THERE'S BEEN GROWING CONCERN
ABOUT BOTH THE WATER AND THE
DETERIORATING INFRASTRUCTURE
HOLDING IT.
A TOP STATE REGULATOR CALLED IT
ONE OF THE BIGGEST ENVIRONMENTAL
THREATS IN FLORIDA HISTORY.
IN A 2003 STORY IN THE "ST.
PETERSBURG TIMES."
THE PAPER REPORTING STATE
OFFICIALS FEAR THE WASTE WILL
SPILL INTO TAMPA BAY, KILLING
MILLIONS OF FISH AND DESTROYING
PLANT LIFE FOR MILES.
EVEN WITHOUT FLOODING, THE
CONTROLLED FLOW IS PUMPING
POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS WATER INTO
THE BAY.
ANN SHERWOOD, WHO RUNS A LOCAL
ESTUARY PROGRAM, IS WORRIED
ABOUT THE IMPACT.
>> FOR THE PAST 20 YEARS WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO GET ATTENTION TO
FINAL FOR THE FACILITY.
>> HE SAYS THE NITROGEN AND
PHOSPHOROUS CONCENTRATIONS COULD
FUEL MORE ALGAE BLOOMS WHICH CAN
KILL OFF FISH AND OTHER
WILDLIFE.
>> THE PEOPLE THAT WORK AND LIVE
IN TAMPA BAY HAVE DONE A LOT AND
MADE A LOT OF INVESTMENTS TO GET
THE BAY BACK INTO HEALTHY
CONDITION AS WE SEE IT TODAY.
IT WASN'T ALWAYS LIKE THIS.
SO WHEN THESE EVENTS HAPPENS,
IT'S ALMOST AN INSULT TO THE
COMMUNITY.
>> Reporter: THIS IS THE POINT
AT WHICH THEY ARE TURNING PEOPLE
AROUND.
AUTHORITIES SAY BEYOND THESE
BARRICADES, IT IS NOT SAFE.
NOW AUTHORITIES SAY AFTER THIS
CURRENT SITUATION IS RESOLVED,
THEY WILL WORK TO CLOSE THE
PLANT PERMANENTLY.
BUT THE BIGGER ISSUE, THEY SAY,
IS THAT THERE ARE DOZENS OF
PLANTS LIKE THIS, CRUMBLING
AGING INFRASTRUCTURE, ALL OVER
TH